populism is not a set of policies it is
a rhetoric and it's a way of talking to
people there is left-wing populism and
right-wing populism and again some
people go no there isn't David
there is populist rhetoric from the
right and left
the populist rhetoric from the right is
often used to justify horrible things
right Bernie and Tucker Carlson will
both say the middle class has been
screwed and passed over and not helped
the way it should have been in this
country for a long time great a lot of
people will agree with that Tucker will
say and so to protect you from that we
have to keep the dirty poor immigrants
out and prevent antifa from taking your
house or whatever the case may be that's
important not to ignore